[Music]
so today we cancel another tick tock
personality who's also a body positivity
advocate um mallory burgess describes
herself as an exercise physiologist and
these days has cultivated a pretty
decent following on social media where
she criticizes
so-called diet culture and calls out fat
shaming and tries to explode the myth
um that as she puts it weight can be
easily controlled what's interesting
about ms burgess is that according to my
brief google search anyway like for two
seconds
her own backstory completely undermines
her current stance on the supposed myth
of weight loss in fact the first thing
that popped up
when i went on google and i was trying
to figure out who this person is so i
can cancel them um the first thing that
popped up was a headline in the
baltimore sun from 2014 and this was the
headline
mcdaniel student loses half her body
weight
the article tells us about a mallory
burgess who was so heavy that she
couldn't fit into restaurant booths she
said but now that is in 2014 now she
lost over 150 pounds and found a new
lease on life
fast forward to 2022
and here's what she is now saying
what is something you used to strongly
believe in that you no longer believe in
at all that body weight is something you
can easily change and control
oh look another random person on tick
tock making outrageous claims with no
sources to make them feel better about
their choices
no
andrew i read you know all those
peer-reviewed studies that you never
actually read in your sophomore year
college class i read those for my job
and there is a growing body of research
on weight and body size that is emerging
within the last five years that's
finding a lot of it is genetically
predetermined that all it takes is for
one low chromosome to get a mutation and
oops that person puts on weight very
easily or can't put weight on at all and
sure some of those factors are external
but not nearly as much as the diet
industry will lead you to believe you
know that billion dollar industry whose
primary interest is making sure that you
keep hating yourself so you'll keep
giving them money maybe it's time to
shift our narrative yes i mean how could
anyone think that people can lose weight
just by eating less
i mean
i know why you should think that malory
given that you did that exact thing
and even without your personal history
it should still be obvious that weight
can be controlled maybe not easily
controlled okay so that's where that's
where you get us on the technicality
it's not easy in the sense that
self-discipline isn't necessarily easy
but it can be simply controlled though
so let's just call it that
as i mentioned last week i just read a
book called in the heart of the sea
about a group of 19th century whalers
who were shipwrecked in the middle of
the pacific that's a great book by the
way most of them died of starvation a
few survived the survivors when they
were finally rescued were gaunt and
skeletal there was no obesity among them
in fact there has never been an obese
shipwreck survivor rescued after months
at sea or stranded on an island not one
in history why is that because
they don't have a lot to eat and when
you eat less you lose weight that's the
correlation now i'm not suggesting that
people should starve themselves i'm
merely pointing out the calories you
consume do indeed have a direct and
quite predictable impact on your weight
if weight was purely genetic
then there should be
lots of morbid obesity even in places
where people don't have a lot to eat and
yet when you look at this map for
example a map of
obesity rates by country
it shows that what a coincidence the
countries that have the most to eat and
where people tend to be the most
sedentary also have the most obesity
36 percent united states is obese
in tanzania it's nine percent indonesia
seven percent
isn't that quite an amazing anomaly
all of the purples the rates between
zero and ten percent are all
concentrated in the third world while
the highest rates are all in the first
world
how do you explain that do they not have
the fat gene down there in uh mozambique
we have all the fat genes here and all
the fast food talk about bad luck
but this is uh this is all academic well
uh one thing i can tell you as a
four-star chef myself um amateur chef
but i consider myself a four-star chef
your kitchen is not complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami coda kamikoda taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan kamikoda also uses
steel sourced from mills in japan and
each blade is crafted using techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy duty ash wood
box and makes sure that the knife is
stored safely as well each kamikota
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete our expert
blade smiths forge and shape raw steel
into hardy blades uh polishing and
sharpening them to excruciatingly fine
edge each knife is individually
inspected kamikoto is so confident that
their knives will work for you that each
knife comes with a lifetime guarantee
because of their single beveled edge
kamikoto knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge you just can't
get with other knives they can cut
through your rib eye like butter that is
guaranteed uh camacoto is currently
having a massive extended new year sale
and on top of that sale you can get an
additional fifty fifty dollars off any
purchase you make with discount code
matt walsh so click the link below or go
to kamikoda.com matt walsh and use promo
code matt walsh to save an extra fifty
50 today
mallory has a more recent video that
raises i think some more interesting
points
well the video doesn't really raise
interesting points but interesting
points can be raised in response to it
so here you go
a little psa for the girlies that hop on
this app and do like the latest gross
weekly body checking trend or do a what
i eat in a day and flash their abs or
just generally fish for compliments that
they are in fact not fat come here
stop doing free labor for the patriarchy
the hierarchy of bodies where one is
considered the best that was designed by
men maybe you've noticed that
heterosexual men have an incredibly
narrow definition of what's attractive
and heterosexual women have like a much
broader one
that's by design if your feminism does
not include fighting fat phobia and body
liberation it's not feminism that's just
another wing of the patriarchy babes and
there might come a day where you
gain weight
and you're still gonna need feminism
then because if you think men are awful
when you're thin
oof
i got really bad news for you you don't
need to trash other body types to make
you feel good about yourself
okay
first of all
the patriarchy
she says that you know they're doing
free labor for the patriarchy i want to
be clear the patriarchy does not expect
women to do free labor
we will happily pay you 70 cents for
every dollar a man earns second
you notice how how people are who are
not thin
always feel entitled to tell people who
are thin how they should and shouldn't
feel about their bodies so for all the
talk about fat shaming the fact is
the only kind of socially acceptable
body shaming that you ever encounter in
our culture today is the kind you just
heard in that video
third most importantly here's a point
that i've been wanting to make for a
while and um and our friend mallory has
given me the opening much of this body
positivity stuff is very thinly veiled
misinjury okay the body positivity
people most of them really just hate men
and i don't mean that they hate men just
because the body positivity stuff is
never meant to encourage men but only
women
all of the fat people we're supposed to
celebrate are women all of them
and that's true but that's not why i'm
saying this i'm saying it because of of
what she just said people like mallory
don't like the traditional feminine form
because for one thing
it takes some work to maintain and
they're too lazy and second because
that's the the form that men prefer
so she says with disdain that men have a
very narrow conception of what they find
attractive as opposed to women who are
more expansive
now the second part of that isn't really
true just ask any out-of-shape single
guy with no money
how easy it is to find a woman who will
give him the time of day he probably is
not going to think that women are all
that open-minded when it comes to their
attractions that's not going to be his
lived experience
um no women broadly speaking look for
certain things in men men look for
certain things in women the things they
look for are different and the way they
look for those things is also different
because men are much more visual by
nature but it's not accurate to say that
one group is more enlightened than the
other now we're speaking in general
terms here again but it's certainly
certainly not accurate generally to say
that
men want women who look gaunt and
famished
that was a trend on the fashion runways
for a while
if any men were responsible for that it
would have been gay men not
heterosexuals we had nothing to do with
that that's not what we're after
men like all of the things that
everybody already knows thinner waist
curvier hips longer legs obviously men
are attracted to breasts to the feminine
form in other words
men are also attracted to things that
are perhaps
noticed on a more subconscious level
like facial symmetry though women are
attracted to that too
so why do men like these things
well perhaps the first answer to people
like mallory should be we like it
because we do
piss off we shouldn't have to justify
our sexual attraction to you any more
than you're presumably willing to
justify yours to us
especially when we're simply pursuing
the same things in women that billions
of other men have pursued throughout
history it's all very normal and healthy
one of the big things that makes these
attributes attractive to men
you know hips breasts and so on youth as
well is that it's a marker of fertility
our attraction to the feminine form is
biological it's a product not a
patriarchy but of evolutionary biology
a feminine woman with the classic sort
of hourglass shape or something close to
it signals health and vitality obesity
signals sickness
obese women also have more problems with
their fertility fertility which again
shows why men don't find it attractive a
man
whether it's in the forefront of his
mind or not
is looking for a woman with whom he can
start a family
that's why the personality traits that
men find most attractive women because
it's not all about looks it's also it
there is also an element of personality
there but all of the personality traits
that men find attractive in women are
all of the ones that will make her a
good wife and mother not the ones that
will make her a good ceo okay not the
ones that will make her successful in
business
but the ones that will make her a good
wife and mother is she caring is she is
she compassionate is she affectionate uh
does she have a maternal instinct these
are the things that men are looking for
and that's also why
the most unattractive and repulsive
woman to a man
is an obese feminist
because she lacks literally everything
that a heterosexual man wants everything
which only makes her
more bitter to straight men which only
makes her more repugnant to them by
extension which only increases her
bitterness and it becomes this vicious
cycle
none of this is the fault of men we're
just being who we are
wanting what we want okay
and we don't have to justify that to
anyone least of all mallory because
today she is
i'm sorry to say canceled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends